You can add a new empty table to your
database with the create table command.
When you create a table, you'll give
the name of the table, and the names and
the types of each column.
You can also set constraints on each
column, and on the row as a whole.
We'll talk about constraints shortly,
but for now let's focus on types.
Here's the simplest form of the create
table command that doesn't have any
constraints, only columns with their
types and gives the table a name.
Now we've dealt with text and
integer types previously.
And back in lesson two,
I gave you a big long list of lots and
lots of types that SQL supports.
The exact set of types that you can use
will vary from system to system though.
If you're working with a database system
that doesn't natively support the type
you need,
there's usually a way to work around it.
For instance, PostgreSQL has
a specific type for IP addresses, but
MySQL does not.
MySQL programmers usually use an integer
or a text string to store IP addresses.
Of the databases we've used in this
course PostgreSQL has a proper type for
dates and times.
But SQLite actually just
stores dates as strings.